com isso me por isso não vamos sair
[Aplausos]
quem olha vocês eu ia ser mais difícil e
ao ias eu achei que já estava lá é a
letra é de graça
cada bloco um computador hrt fss corre
[Música]
aí a mãe ouvir nossa maior confiança no
mercado de procuro em cada de manter
mateus no governo é votar o fim de seu
filho e marcela inter eu fui a trapaça
mulher eu que a mulher na fila você vai
passar não é só pegar um cd idéia é
soltar lei
ai fala em brigar você chamá-lo
banhar-se muito obrigado sr
hoje a gente assim
bom é isso
a diferença do rio de onde se quer
físicas quer viver como nem por isso
recebi aqui perguntas eram tão solta a
bola que eu gosto mais que o bope já
pode provar nada e vai morrer gente fala
e faz bater e eu era sócio que mora
sozinho é bom porque você passa a ser
direto quanto massa ao cm que só seria
um ex presidente só na família
o bom é que você quiser
[Música]
além da demora no lugar do chamado de
internet wi fi em pó
[Música]
aí é bonito tem muitas amostras no
shopping rio claro e é isso aí
nesse show
[Aplausos]
é mais intenções que eu nunca vou se
realizar
quem na pet fui eu tentei tentei chegar
à vontade da mulher é assim que chegou à
área que até de custos e s
eu vi que faltava o povo querido sempre
[Música]
um bombeiro mas volpi uma irmã minha mãe
eu vou tentar combinar essa nova york
cai na rede eu sou o teu é só um bom
negócio com blatter a lei que ela me rio
ela desvendou tom é legal essa obra tem
mais filho não quer melhor foi pão na
rua irmão bateu por essência partilhar
é a gente é muita coisa no sexo é uma
coisa de deus
instituída no matrimônio mas é muito
carente em 351 6 da orla de poemas sabe
de algo que tenha pecado
aquele que não gosta dele